as an app developer there's a widening
gap between where you are and where you
want to be most legacy apps can't
support the rapid pace of change in
demand for agile development and the
faster delivery of innovative apps and
updates you have mixed workloads and you
operate in a hybrid world while you
continue to have some traditional
mission-critical apps on-premises new
applications have to be container in
kubernetes ready today's applications
are developed with containerized
middleware that can make development
deployment and monitoring easier and
faster
how can your enterprise compete IBM
WebSphere Liberty's rich set of
capabilities and api's bridge the gap
between old and new apps WebSphere
Liberty is delivered in containers that
can use kubernetes to manage deployment
and orchestration Liberty is a modern
flexible runtime that's designed with a
cloud in mind without sacrificing the
ability to support traditional workloads
minimize server size means faster
startup and a smaller footprint for
increased scalability in a cloud
environment without sacrificing the
performance throughput and security
required by enterprise applications and
WebSphere Liberty increases developer
productivity with consistent tools and
processes built on open source plus
WebSphere Liberty's flexible licensing
models mean you have control over your
startup costs and the ability to evolve
at your own pace paying only for what
you need when you need it
bridging the app development gap is
easier with a trusted partner by your
side modernize your development with one
of the most flexible security rich and
reliable platforms available IBM
WebSphere Liberty learn more today
you